[Musique]
je vous souhaite la bienvenue
nous sommes en 2003 écrivain cuirasse et
une dans la ville de quatre millions
d'habitants et qui n'en a pas vraiment
de différence en fait de manille
quand vous avez vu à privas c'est
essentiellement de richesse c'est quoi
c'est le soleil et sont des ressources
humaines c'est quand les choses
classiques une présence chez nous ici au
mali
ma peau mais vous arrivez à privas et
que vous conduit si vous arrivez la
première chose que vous ne manquerez à
plus tard c'est certainement cette ferme
solaire parce qu'un effet appuiera les
gens ils utilisent essentiellement
l'énergie solaire pour alimenter tout ce
qu'ils font est là quelque chose qui va
sans doute finir votre ration faire cela
aussi tous ses usines mais des usines
qui sont maintenus détenus par des
jeunes des jeunes de 25 ans les jeunes
de 24 ans a déjà de 50
et dans ces usines qui fabriquent des
produits avec des tablettes les
ordinateurs de l'imagination les
physiques - tic
il faudrait tout sauf et technologique
et maintenant comment j'étais arrivé à
plus grave est que cela est logiquement
site est aussi un matin les enfants
devraient partir à l'époque c'est dans
une famille je rencontre une maman
d'inès je vous y a pas d'apporter son
départ libre
elle m'a regardé bizarrement est en fait
les gens prenaient les appels dans votre
avenir compromis n'est bon et maintenant
office est ce que tu dis que dieu fait
je faisais beaucoup qui sont souvent
savignac bonne figure et que j'appelle
donne wade aurait en fait chez nous les
enfants n'ont pas forcément besoin
d'aidé dans une classe à l'état pur car
la cipra forçats il transporte sur les
tablettes
les enfants apprennent à lire à décrire
et ils appellent tous à travers cet
ajustement
il appelle les sciences il appelle la
biologie les mathématiques qu'ils
appellent toutes sortes de choses mais
ils apprennent aussi l'atrocité ils
apprenaient traces
les droits et qui sait tous que cela
relance évidemment ils sont un peu anar
parce que chez nous il faut aller à
l'école et vos bûcher exactement quand
le prof et le dit ensuite tout répéter
qu'il dit et après tu va peut-être
réussir mes choix je veux les gens
semblaient avancer c'est parce que
justement ils ont promis que l'éducation
était la base des choses qu'eux ils ont
tout fait ou que l'élection puisse être
partout où les gens y voient la deuxième
main sur l'extraordinaire fera jamais un
pour échanger avec coeur la ram a
justement au niveau des coûts élevés
c'était leur connaissance de la société
leur rapport à la vie et surtout leur
compréhension commune et besoins sociaux
avoué récemment a expliqué un jour que
chez eux
personne aucune femme - en donnant la
vie et que c'était du passé aux fins
n'existait plus jeu donc c'est être bien
qu'on soit fort et là je m'étais rendu
compte
effectivement c'est d'éveil pour les
avaient réussi il avait fait et elle
s'en fiche pour la santé maternelle et
infantile pouvait être suivie de façon
intelligente
chaque femme enceinte n'était pas avec
téléphone rouge et du design c'étaient
des mots entre 10
et démontre qu'ils pouvaient dire à
chaque instant assez prendra qualité de
l'état est-ce qu'elle avait besoin
d'aller consulter immédiatement
est-ce que elle était en bonne santé
parler des enfants étaient dans la même
situation
j'ai subi par les technologies de
l'information et de la communication à
courir et les décisions sont colligées
comment les entrées sont ils ont investi
dans l'intimité
oui j'essaie d'aller si vite et la
première question qu'on pourrait tout à
fait se poser tout de suite c'est vers
sais pas l'expliquer eh bien ce sont ces
technologies qui vont permettre de
pouvoir apporter un changement politique
ou des pour apporter des connaissances
avancées et améliorer nos habitudes et
de construire l'avenir et mouvements
internes politique interne du
développement économique et social et
appelé laurent picard ils ont tellement
bien pauvre et chez eux quand une
décision de la crise elle se prend à
travers des parents et vos logique
complètement points
imaginons que ils décident de voter une
loi qu elles font une loi qui fait que
juin à l'âge de 23 ans doit se présenter
pour fo pisano
les résultats d'entreprises en europe
alors cette loi va être envoyé sur une
plateforme technologique et 7,4 en
technologique est une plateforme qui a
émis à la fin de l'étape et les acteurs
de la société civile de quick d une loi
et sur cette plateforme
qu'est ce qui se passe parfaitement et
qui se passe et puis chaque citoyen et
chaque citoyen va aller si loin
une notification tout le monde sans
exception précise la notification à
partir de cette modification
chaque citoyen pourrait alors donner son
opinion sur l'histoire
ils vous ont fustigé voulons donc sur la
loi y prodigue
ainsi les décisions par rapport à cette
loi est ce qu'il faudrait la faire
passer à situer le faire passer est ce
que le peuple pense ça se fait ensemble
voilà quoi ils formulent ils ont réussi
à faire ça a brûlé
parce que là bas les dirigeants sont
d'abord des citoyens avant d'être
détruit et parce qu'ils sont citoyens
ils ont profits que s'ils veulent être
dans la démocratie
ils ont besoin n'existe mans de faire en
sorte mes chiens qu'une décision puisse
émaner du peuple et parce que si nous
révèle un autre exemple typique sur la
mort parce que cette loi elle a été
discutée à la mort grâce aux
technologies d'information
mais ce n'est pas le peuple et que le
vote qui va se faire sur cette loi est
un sport inventé et à nager par le peu
alors 17 corps est mise en oeuvre elle
c'est la gloire par le peut pour le feu
est dans l'intérêt et l'unité du peuple
parce que simplement un tas d'infos le
processus de production de cette loi
c'est tout appel de type est ou n'est ce
pas dans la sphère définition de la
diminution de la rénovation a privé
quelque chose d'impressionnant se passe
à chaque fois qu'on vous n'en voulez
vous ne voulez pas rentré du groupe
avant le 2 septembre de sept essais en
savez
c'est la qualité extraordinaire inné et
jean exemple une richesse citoyens de
polir et dégagent quand vous discutez
avec les enfants du clae vous avez
l'impression d'une dispute avec les
affaiblit h 10 quand vous discutez avec
un ancien dont une personne d'une autre
génération
vous avez toujours l'impression que ce
monsieur à 7 août 2007 il a passé toute
sa vie et cela parce que la poudre et
ils sont passés à faire de
l'investissement de masse les
investissements des masses dans une
approche tout à fait démocratique et
anti la mèche et ses 26 ans
ils ont plaidé telle sorte que la
connaissance puis c'est la toute
première chose sur laquelle la
population veut refonder tout son savoir
faire sans savoir être et surtout son
sabre entre partager et la deuxième
chose la plus extraordinaire encore
privés
c'est les cinq enfants du fonds que vous
avez des appelés
qu'est ce que vous allez voir vous allez
voir gratuitement quelque chose des
formes il est un fait que à chaque
instant le peuple est capable de lui
dire exactement combien on a des
si l'on est bien tard le même v6 de
construire un pont il va aller voter
pour un je souhaite construire un pont
vous allez juste de tout se discute à
maman et elle se fait de façon dont il
est l'un des rares à tous puisque et
tout ça donc d'être le maire dit je vais
faire ça avec qui la paix qui arrive sur
le contrat qui a exécuté pour la série
ds qui sont satisfaits qu'ils arrivent à
voir tout ça via le téléphone mobile via
l'internet et donc vous d extrêmement en
forme wii est sans doute l'une des
villes les plus futuristes que nous
n'allons jamais rencontrés ne pas
jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais pourtant ce
n'est pas si futuriste et sain et si
nous revenons tout son talent a
maintenant revenons un peu là je sais
vous avez voyagé
donc on avait tourné nous sommes comme
annick nous sommes en 2018 pour ce que
je vous dis là c'est possible à courir
et ils ont les ressources naturelles
notamment d'électricité conduit à partir
de soleil pourtant ici on a des
cinquantenaires on peut utiliser sa déjà
alimenté tout internet
cette tablette ici au mali qui est aussi
son fabriquer un régime malien
il ya une smart c'était manière c'est
des tablettes du produit
c'est tout à fait utilisable dans le
secteur de la santé nous avons tellement
notre côté
logique qui permette dessus de la santé
maternelle et infantile sur le sexe
inopérant spécifiquement le cas de
l'éducation on va devoir chez nos
voisins il dispose d'une patron qui
s'appelle classe qui permettent à des
centaines de milliers d'enfants de
pouvoir apprendre à l'école sans être
forcée d'aller est allé apprendre dans
les classes si nous voulons parler de
change entre les dirigeants et la
population
il est si sync for mobile commun qui
s'appelle monde lui qui aussi a permis à
des centaines de la france je crois
communiquer avec la famille nationale et
vous deuxième jambe
donc tout ce qui se passe à courir et
cette ville futuristic est tout à fait
possible
aujourd'hui si nous voulons bâtir le
futur si nous voulons construire la
démocratie de demain c'est tout de suite
et maintenant des aspects et cela passe
tout simplement pas une volonté commune
a utilisé de façon intelligente et
technologies de l'information et de la
communication pour la population par la
population et d'un unique et d'aimer de
la population
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
ces oasis mans
le père a subi aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose de grand
vassaliser pas si l'amérique ici
jboss application development tutu à
city sans vous cet événement n'aurait
pas eu l'ampleur qu'il avait regardé je
m'en vais amener la prochaine aura et
ingénieur en génie informatique
titulaire d'un master en finance elle a
également promis un féminin depuis son
plus jeune âge et développera devant une
passion pour la lecture et l'écriture
la passion pour l'écriture et son envie
de perdre lcd qui l'ont poussé à acheter
un bloc yamakasi et finit par oublier
110 évasif et le roman familial is the
beast depuis 2007 elle est la directrice
générale de vidéos une annonce qui
accompagne de grandes entreprises on a
deux façons elle est perçue comme le
symbole
ils étaient dix à s'entraîner c'est que
dit la barre vient de la presse
le titre de son discours m qui est la
femme a quitté du futur elle va me dire
je vous demande mon avis à travers le
bonheur
[Applaudissements]
dakar lui 1974 un jeune professeur de
mathématiques et de physique
[Musique]